última semana en la contienda por la
casa blanca y ambos candidatos están
recorriendo el país para tratar de ganar
votantes en los estados más disputados
el demócrata joe biden quien lidera las
encuestas por al menos siete puntos
entro en el tradicional territorio
republicano georgia el estado sureño no
apoyado en demócrata desde 1992 las
divisiones en nuestra nación se están
agrandando la gente enojada está molesta
la ira y sospecha están creciendo y
nuestras heridas están haciendo más
profundas
desde un autocine de orlando el ex
presidente barack obama impulsó la
candidatura de joe biden y arremetió
contra el mandatario donald trump
y una semana hasta la elección más
importante de nuestras vidas
escuchen tienen un presidente ahora
mismo que quiere crédito completo por
una economía que heredó y rechaza toda
responsabilidad por una pandemia que
ignoro desde washington a las vegas'
pasando por michigan wisconsin y
nebraska donald chan continuó con una
intensa ronda de mítines haciendo
esperar hasta cuatro horas bajo la
lluvia a sus seguidores investigan
[Aplausos]
dentro de siete días vamos a ganar el
estado de michigan y vamos a ganar
cuatro años más en la casa blanca
mientras la primera dama melania trump
daba su primer discurso en pensilvania
tras su recuperación del cob y 19 y
reconoció que a veces discrepa con el
estilo comunicativo de donald trump
no siempre estoy de acuerdo con la forma
en que dice las cosas pero es importante
para él que hable directamente a la
gente a la que sirve
más de 67 millones de personas te han
votado hasta ahora un tercio en persona
y dos tercios por correo un récord
histórico de cara a los comicios del 3
de noviembre